Speaker 1: All right, next.
Good Trump story.
A Donald Trump has released a bizarre, incredibly
hyperbolic attack on Senate now Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell.
And this is delightful.
This is just delightful.
So remember that on Monday, I told you about
the growing and brewing civil war happening
within the Republican Party.
What were the two sides of the Civil War?
I explained on Monday.
Well, one side is Trumpist Republicans, all
of whom voted against the bipartisan infrastructure
bill passed by the House on Friday.
Trump is Republicans who said, We don't want
this.
We're not helping Joe Biden.
We're not doing any of it.
On the other side of the Republicans have
brought civil war were the 13 Republicans
who crossed party lines in the House and did
vote for the tiny, comparatively tiny infrastructure
bill passed by the House.
On Friday, 13 Republicans crossed party lines.
The Trump House Republicans went nuts, demanding
the removal and promising to primary and ruin
the careers.
Of those 13 Republicans who said This is a
bill that I'm going to vote for, and I said
at the time, let them fight, encourage them
to fight.
This is what the left needs because quite
frankly, things aren't looking particularly
good for the left right now in the aftermath
of last Tuesday's elections.
Looking at 2022, the left needs something.
Democrats need something.
Democrats in the left, they overlap a little,
but they are two different things.
But it's not looking good for either right
now.
So this is good.
Well, we have another.
Could we call it a rejoinder in the Republican
Civil War?
Donald Trump has released a statement trashing
Mitch McConnell for not passing infrastructure
while he was president.
Remember much of why Trump is opposed to Republicans?
Helping pass infrastructure now is regardless
of whether it would be good for the country,
and Trump said while he was president, it
would be good for the country.
Trump doesn't want this to be a victory for
Biden because Trump wasn't able to get it
done.
And so Trump doesn't want any Republicans
to help Joe Biden because by helping Biden,
it makes Trump's lack of passing infrastructure
while he was president look worse.
Is that true?
Yeah, maybe to some degree.
Maybe to some degree.
But as Business Insider points out, it was
Trump who walked away from a $2 trillion dollar
deal back in 2019.
Take a look at the statement from Donald Trump
released yesterday through his Save America
PAC.
Donald Trump said Why is it that old crow
Mitch McConnell voted for a terrible Democrat
socialist infrastructure plan now, by the
way?
If Joe Biden's $1.2 trillion plan is socialist,
how is the two trillion dollar deal that Trump
seemed to want but ultimately walked away
from?
How is that not doubly socialist?
Because it's B.S.
That's that's why I'm Trump going on to say
and induced others in his party to do likewise
when he was incapable of getting a great infrastructure
plan, one thing to be put forward by me and
the Republican Party.
He continuously said he couldn't get it passed,
just like I had to go around him to get the
very popular southern border wall built, which
caused great delay but could now be completed
in one month by Biden.
I think there's three lies in that sentence.
All of the infrastructure money two trillion
dollars would have gone into real infrastructure,
roads, bridges, tunnels, airports, etc..
Also, why did Mitch give the Democrats a two
month hiatus just long enough for them to
figure it all out when they were completely
ready to fold?
This is an unhinged man.
It was again, it was Trump who walked away
from that $2 trillion dollar deal.
He says it was McConnell.
Business Insider also writes about this.
In May 2019, Democratic leaders and the Trump
administration had a productive round of negotiations
around offloaded $2 trillion infrastructure
package.
But the deal crumbled over the Democratic
controlled House investigations into Trump
after the release of then special counsel
Robert Mueller's report during a second meeting
with House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and then Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer.
Trump walked out within three minutes of negotiations
instead of walking in happily to a meeting.
I walk in to look at people that just said
I was doing a cover up.
I don't do cover ups, Trump said at a press
conference.
Yeah.
So remember it was Trump that walked away.
Now, Trump says he was justified in walking
away, but that it was still Donald Trump who
walked away from that negotiation.
So why is this good?
Well, it's good because things are looking
really bad for Democrats right now.
Things just aren't looking good.
You've got a contingent of the left that might
describe itself as the progressive left, although
I am on the progressive left and I think that
we should actually be working with centrist
Democrats to extract any victories that we
can.
But you've got a portion of the progressive
left that still has a sort of burn it down.
Acceleration is mentality that is going to
hurt Democrats in their possibility of getting
anything done.
Democrats are terrible at campaigning and
the McAuliffe campaign in Virginia just a
disaster.
It's looking really bad for 2022 is the point.
And right now, I think if we had a Trump vs.
Biden election held today, I think Trump wins
easily.
So the biggest gift that Republicans can really
give Democrats right now is to fight among
themselves.
It's a really sad commentary on the state
of the Democratic Party.
I'm not denying that it is.
It is wild that the best thing Democrats have
going for them right now is that Democrats
that Republicans rather are fighting with
themselves.
Trump, Republicans fighting with the Republicans
that voted for infrastructure, Trump Republicans
fighting with Mitch McConnell because of his
actions in the Senate.
It's sadly and this is I mean, listen.
You know, I'm not I'm not a Democrat, as many
of you know.
I don't care about the Democratic Party.
This is a really embarrassing moment for the
Democratic Party, given that the most optimistic
thing anybody can point to is Republicans
seem to be damaging themselves, says very
little about Democrat ability to get anything
actually done.
But it's a good thing that this is happening
for the country in the sense that a distracted
Republican Party, a divided Republican Party,
is a Republican Party that will struggle to
get anything done and may also even struggle
to obstruct the things that Democrats want
to get done.
We'll see.
We'll see but encourage the Civil War, and
it doesn't seem to be stopping anytime soon.